joining us now south carolina senator
lindsey graham senator um
i want to ask you for a reaction to that
angle because
corporations have long considered
republicans
to be their greatest defenders against
the high tax
high you know big regulation of the left
and the democrats
if they do this to georgia are you
prepared to say all bets are off
with these corporations
well i wish everybody could hear what
you just said you summed it
summed it up pretty well number one
these ceos are full of crap
they're running scared georgia is trying
to make sure that everybody can vote
legally georgia has a 17-day
early voting period including weekends
delaware where president biden's from
has no early voting you don't have to
have a reason to cast an absentee ballot
in georgia
you just want to so you can vote
robustly in georgia but now you got to
prove you are who you are
and that's driving the left crazy
because it's harder to cheat
to delta to microsoft to coca-cola
what do you think about hr1 are you okay
with hr1
where redistricting will be done at the
federal level not the state level
where ballot harvesting will be the law
of the land that we will obliterate
voter id laws if hr one passes corporate
america you're screwed beyond belief
there'll be no limit to what democrats
can do to your tax rates
and to your regulation structure so if
you really care about the future of your
business and your shareholders
you'll speak up against h.r 1 the
biggest power grab in the history of the
united states
and while denouncing the georgia voter
law senator graham
the coca-cola ceo james quincy also said
our focus is now on supporting federal
legislation that protects voting access
and addresses voter suppression across
the country
that is you're the dumbest ceo
in the history of america because if hr1
becomes law
ballot harvesting will be the law of the
land states will be run
by the most liberal people in washington
there will be a
federally funded elections redistricting
will be done
by liberal democrats the federal
election commission will be partisan
if you think that's a good deal for
corporate america or hard-working
americans
then you're crazy and you need to be
fired i think they all need to be asked
tomorrow
do you support h.r one that's now
pending before the senate because if you
do
as a corporate ceo you're destroying
your shareholders ability to
to thrive and survive that senator
i laid out in the angle most of these
ceos have
no hesitation about bowing down
to china with everything they're doing
both in hong kong their plans
i'm sure in taiwan uh what they've done
to their own people in china they have
no problem
and now they're going to lecture georgia
and they think they're not going to deal
with the wrath of the american people
give me a break well what they're doing
in georgia is requiring you to prove you
are who you are when you vote by mail
which is a good idea
i want people to be able to vote
robustly easily but i want to make sure
that it's an
honest vote so the people enjoy the ceos
they don't know whether
joe biden has no idea what's in the the
georgia election law jim crow
was a time in our country where people
were beaten so they couldn't vote
dogs were were unleashed on them they
had
poll taxes they had literacy tests
to compare that to georgia is an offense
to the people in georgia
it's what the left does to try to get us
all to bend to their will as you
said i'm tired of it joe manchin do what
west virginia wants and you'll be fine
don't let jim clyburn and the radical
left uh
beat you up and and get you to submit to
voting for h.r one
if you care about the people of west
virginia arizona and north carolina you
name all these states
then stand up for the ability of your
state to conduct the fair election the
way they see fit
don't turn all the power over the
federal government
major league baseball better be very
careful the viewers of major league
baseball are very conservative
uh senator before we go after your
recent visit uh
to the border i believe you have a
message for president biden and dr
fauci what is it yeah
well uh president biden said to the
texas ranger baseball team
talking about baseball you need to
listen to dr fauci about urging people
to come to the baseball
game opening day dr fauci
you need to go to the border and here's
what you will see
you will see 900 people in a room built
for 80.
you will see people living on top of
each other a 10
positive rate where the positive people
intermingle with everybody else
and all these illegal immigrants are
dumped off in texas and the rest of the
country
so dr faucia you need to go to the
border and if you're not compelled to
shut down this illegal immigration
program
i don't want to hear anything you got to
say about baseball or restaurants
it is the biggest in my view covet
spreader
in the world along the border where
thousands of legal immigrants are coming
to this country
positive 10 positive rate intermingled
with each other
dropped out all over texas and the rest
of america so
i'm not worried about the baseball game
in texas i'm worried about illegal
immigrants infecting the whole country
given the policies that biden has so